en ile de france merci madame la parole
et à monsieur jean-sébastien vialatte
merci merci monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à madame la ministre
des affaires sociales et de la santé
elle concerne le rapport de mes
collègues jean louis touraine et arnaud
robinet sur la mise en application de la
loi entend répondre de la biologie
médicale de 2013
la loi de 2013 prévoit que les
laboratoires de biologie médicale
dispose au 1er novembre 2016 d'une
accréditation portant sur 50% des
examens effectués pour pouvoir continuer
de fonctionner le rapport de mes
collègues mentionne que le cofrac comité
français d'accréditation est dans
l'incapacité fausse d'auditeurs en
nombre suffisant d'effectuer les
évaluations nécessaires à cette
accréditation
d'ailleurs le cofrac écrivait dès mai
2015 que les laboratoires ayant déposé
dans les délais des demandes
d'accréditation ne pourrez pas tous être
accréditée à temps vous êtes madame
consciente du problème puisque vous avez
publié en date du 11 novembre 2015
un arrêté simplifiant les règles
d'accréditation
malgré tout le rapport des messieurs
touraine et robinets estime que 300
laboratoires sur 1000 ne pourront pas
être accréditée à temps du fait du
cofrac
avec le risque de se voir retirer leur
autorisation d'exercer
madame la ministre les biologistes ont
fait des efforts considérables pour être
au rendez-vous de la loi il ne saurait
être pénalisés parce que le cofrac
mandatés par l'état et qui détient le
monopole de l'accréditation ne peut
faire face à ses obligations
madame la ministre quelles dispositions
allez vous prendre pour que le
laboratoire qui n'ont pas du fait du
cofrac l'accréditation au 31 octobre
puisse continuer d'exercer
je vous remercie la balle est à madame
marisol touraine ministre des affaires
sociales de la santé et des droits des
femmes
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
et vialatte
vous avez raison de souligner que c'est
l'un des points majeurs de la réforme de
la biologie médicale que de mettre en
place un processus d'accréditation qui
vient garantir la qualité des procédures
et la fiabilité des examens l'
ordonnance du 2 janvier 2010 qui a été
ratifié par la loi du 13 mai 2013 impose
comme vous l'avez dit que cette
certification accréditation se fasse par
paliers successifs et au 1er novembre
chaque laboratoire devra être accréditée
à 50% et cela montera jusqu'à 100 % au
1er novembre 2020 le cofrac a rencontré
des difficultés et je veux saluer à mon
tour l'excellence du travail réalisé par
vos collègues jean louis touraine et
arnaud robinet qui posent plusieurs
pistes d'évolution parmi ces pistes je
veux dire que je privilégie la voie de
l'optimisation des procédures du cofrac
concrètement de quoi s'agit-il il s'agit
sans remettre en question la qualité de
la procédure de facilité
examen par le cofrac des demandes qui
lui sont présentés et je veux préciser
que la quasi-totalité des laboratoires à
déposer au jour où je vous parle
une demande d'accréditation nous
simplifions les démarches nous avons
engagé un processus d'augmentation du
nombre des évaluateurs de
diversification des évaluateurs et nous
avons avec le cofrac défini des
priorités pour que les laboratoires qui
n'ont jamais été évalué le soit en
premier de cette manière il nous semble
que nous pouvons tenir l'objectif fixé
par la loi sans qu'il soit nécessaire de
procéder à un report de la date d'entrée
en vigueur de l'accréditation mais vous
le voyez monsieur le député nous sommes
très attentifs
je suis leinada